la circulation de l'épidémie est de
moins en moins actives en france mais
n'est pas pour autant sous contrôle les
taux d'incidence reste un taux élevé sur
tout le territoire
c'est dans ce contexte de fragile des
crues du coc vite que l'académie de
médecine s'est prononcé pour la
vaccination obligatoire relançant ainsi
les débats pour plus de précisions nous
retrouvons tout de suite david khalifa
bonsoir d'asile elle les réactions n'ont
pas manqué un dans de suite à cette
déclaration surtout dans le milieu
médical
un peu moins du côté des politiques
effectivement elle stéphanie a beaucoup
de réactions parce qu'on tient négative
1 suite à cette déclaration de patrick
berche plusieurs spécialistes sont
montés au créneau cas les français on se
souvient était déjà sceptique à l'idée
de cette vaccination jean paul hamon est
président d'honneur de la fédération des
médecins de france ne veut surtout pas à
brusquer les français a dû côté de la rs
on préconise de l' impatience écoute et
ce n'est pas le moment de braquer les
gens inutilement
on commence à avoir suffisamment de
doses pour vacciner les gens laissons
faire on verra bien au mois de septembre
octobre dans quelle situation sera mais
parti comme c'est parti on est parti
pour vacciner près de 10 millions de
personnes par mois il faut être patient
pour l'instant plein de gens veulent se
faire vacciner et on n'a pas assez de
vaccins
les rendez vous ne sont pas faciles à
obtenir le jour où tous ceux qui
voulaient se faire vacciner se sont fait
vacciner et qu'on voit un frein dans la
campagne de vaccination liés à
l'adhésion
peut être qu'on pourra se poser la
question rendre un vaccin obligatoire
peut être en train à l'adhésion
vaccinale vous savez comment sont les
français
il suffit de leur dire que quelque chose
est obligatoire pour qu'ils imaginent
quelque chose de louche derrière pour
l'académie de médecine je le rappelle ça
serait le moyen le plus sûr pour
atteindre cette fameuse immunité à
collective à ce qui signifie à 90% de la
population vaccinée mais l'aspect
d'obligations a subjugué certains
politiques notamment florian philippot
le
l'heure des patriotes appelle les
français à se révolter
regardez voilà nous y sommes
l'académie de médecine préconise de
rendre obligatoire le vaccin pour de
nombreuses catégories de français et de
vacciner enfants et adolescents la
terreur qu'ovide east franchi une
nouvelle étape
réveillons nous c'est l'une des rares
réactions politiques qu'on a pu observer
sur les réseaux sociaux peu d'élus
souhaite remettre le sujet sur la table
dans la majorité comme dans l'opposition
car la question considérée comme de
santé publique par l'académie à de
médecine restent très sensibles et david
la question évidemment que se posent
beaucoup de français c'est savoir si le
gouvernement peut donc l'imposer et
rendre effectivement cette vaccination
obligatoire et bien stéphanie dans ce
contexte d'urgence sanitaire tout est
possible mais l exécutif a toujours été
contre cette idée emmanuel macron écarté
lui même cette hypothèse la semaine
dernière affirmant le respect de la vie
de chacun je préfère marcher par la
conviction selon ses mots mais gabriel
atallah lui était un peu plus évasif cet
après midi le porte parole du
gouvernement a dit entendre ses
recommandations ce sont des études que
nous regardons en fin de citation mais
notre objectif reste de vacciner ce qui
est le souhaite pour le moment
voilà l'option est sur la table nul
doute que si une telle décision est
prise à les anti mac serait furieux pour
le moment ils sont 20% de la population
selon les derniers chiffres annoncés
d'autant plus que pour le moment dans le
monde aucun pays n'a contraint ses
citoyens se faire vacciner
merci david kelly faron direct de
l'académie de médecine